[Musique]
en
au milieu du pacifique navigue un fin
voile y ait là sternes fuligineuses
c'est un paradoxe vivant que cette
voyageuse un oiseau marin qui ne
mouillent jamais ses ailes de peur de se
noyer pour ces haltes où ses amours elle
se pose parfois sur des îles fumantes
perdu dans l'océan
pourquoi ce choix il faut chercher la
réponse à plusieurs kilomètres sous la
surface dans les abysses sur ses fonds
montagneux vie la crevette d'alvin une
énigme elle aussi elle a su trouver son
chemin dans tous les océans du monde
alors qu'elle est aveugle un oiseau et
un crustacé
qu'est ce qui peut bien rapproché deux
créatures aussi dissemblables les lieux
qu'elle partage des volcans sous marins
qui se transforme en il
l'une dans les abysses l'autre en
surface la crevette et la sterne ont un
destin commun leur survie ne tient qu'à
ses oasis surgit des profondeurs marines
[Musique]
l'océan pacifique un tiers de la surface
de la terre repose sur la plus grande
des plaques tectoniques
ces morceaux de croûte terrestre qui
parfois s'entrechoquent dans la ceinture
de feu du pacifique se trouve 90% des
volcans du globe et les fosses abyssales
les plus profondes
la sternes fuligineuses et la crevette
d'alvin vivent toutes deux au tour des
archipels nés de ces phénomènes
géologiques
[Musique]
par les fissures ainsi ouverte
le sang de la terre se déverse au grand
jour
[Musique]
au terme de leur voyage à travers
l'écorcé terrestre
les roches en fusion sont brusquement
refroidis par l'océan
tant qu'il est fluide le magma s'écoule
paisiblement
il se pétrifie au contact de l'air mais
surtout de l'eau de telles éruptions
peuvent durer des millions d'années
comme ici à hawaï
[Musique]
les rivières de roche signé ont créé une
montagne immerger de plus de 11
kilomètres de haut si on la mesure
depuis le plancher de l'océan
c'est la plus haute du monde et elle
continue de grandir
[Musique]
et
dans le cas de l'af plus visqueuse les
rencontres avec l'eau sont explosives et
si brève que seuls des navigateurs de
passage ont pu les saisir
[Musique]
en l'espace de trois jours cette
éruption aura créé trois nouveaux
cratères dans l'immensité du pacifique
il arrive que des ils surgissent loin
des regards ni vu ni connu
cette nouvelle terre de cendres par
exemple n'a toujours pas de nom
mais à défaut de nom elle a déjà une
fonction elle sert de repaire aux
nomades de l'océan
les baleines connaissent mieux que
quiconque les contrées sous marine
vallet montagne dont cette île perdue
n'est que l'un des sommets alors que
pour la sterne comme pour nous la
géographie des reliefs de l'océan se
limite aux parties émergées
elle pourrait s'arrêter sur cet îlot
marquer une étape dans son voyage au
long cours
les allemands n'éprouve pas le besoin là
encore la sternes fuligineuses est un
phénomène dès lors qu'elle a pris son
envol
elle peut passer quatre ans dans les
airs sans se poser une seule fois il lui
suffit de pêcher du bout du bec et de
dormir envol en bloquant ses ailes
[Musique]
quand elle a perdu trop d'altitude elle
interrompt son sommeil pour ne pas
risquer de toucher l'eau car elle ne
sécrète pas assez de ces tuiles
imperméabilisante dont les oiseaux
marins enduisent leur plumage si elles
se posent à la surface elle s'imbibe
comme une éponge et se noie celle ci
sera bientôt au bout du voyage
aujourd'hui en âge de se reproduire elle
rejoint son île natale tôt fois un
dessin sans volcan actif de la ceinture
de feu
[Musique]
mauvaise surprise tôt fois semble des
peuples et pas un congénère en vue ou
qu'elle regarde elle ne voit que des os
brisés vidés de leur contenu
le volcan n'est pour rien dans ce
massacre les coupables les voici
[Musique]
des rats
ces envahisseurs sont arrivés ici dès le
xiiie siècle avec les premiers
navigateurs polynésiens puis européen
[Musique]
ils viennent de dévoré tous les oeufs de
sternes et s'attaque à présent à ceux
d'autres oiseaux marins rien de plus
facile
ils sont posés à même le sol
[Musique]
mon goût
sans défense contre ces pillards aux
dents pointues leicester n'abandonne
généralement le terrain et vont fonder
ailleurs une nouvelle colonie
[Musique]
mais où son parti celle qui niche et ato
fois cette jeune femelle doit rapidement
retrouver ses congénères sinon elle
manquera la saison de reproduction
heureusement elle découvrira bientôt à
l'horizon d'autres panache de fumée
d'autres il
[Musique]
le volcan de thau fois a donné son nom à
toute une chaîne de volcans l'arc deux
fois un chapelet d'îlots placés sous la
souveraineté du royaume des tonga
aligné comme les soldats d'une armée de
pierres ils sont pour la plupart immergé
nous ne connaissons que ceux dont le
sommet des passes de l'eau les plus
anciens ont l'âge des alpes et
proviennent comme elle des mouvements de
l'écorcé terrestre
parfois le sommet d'un volcan sous marin
se trouve suffisamment longtemps près de
la surface et de la lumière pour qu un
récif de corail s'y épanouissent puis un
jour soulevé par en dessous
le volcan émergent sa coiffe de corail
se retrouve hors de l'eau et meurt
les unes il est né
[Musique]
les buissons de calcaire surnom peu à
peu rongé par l'océan
[Musique]
sous l'eau l'érosion est moins féroce
pour atteindre la base de tel ou tel il
faut plonger à plusieurs km de
profondeur
[Musique]
et c'est comme si l'on changé de monde
est de règle des 3 100 m l'eau a épongé
toute la lumière solaire
on ne peut observer les fantômes peuple
en ses ténèbres qu'en allumant de
puissants projecteurs sans eux
voici ce que l'on voit cette méduse est
illuminé de l'intérieur par des
bactéries
il se produit en elle une réaction de
synthèse qui transforme l'énergie
chimique en énergie lumineuse et se cale
marc bijoux s'est lui aussi un adepte de
la bioluminescence comme presque tous
ceux qui vivent dans cette obscurité
profonde
il doit briller pour séduire un
partenaire communiqué ou chasser
certains vecten au fort par exemple tous
très loin l'étrangeté c'est pour mieux
s'adapter à des conditions extrêmes
la température de l'eau de plus en plus
glacial à mesure que l'on descend et sa
pression qui atteint plusieurs centaines
de fois celle de l'air que nous
respirons
longtemps on a pensé que toute vie était
impossible dans les abysses il s'agit au
contraire du plus vaste habitat de la
planète plusieurs millions d'espèces
seraient à y découvrir alors qu à ce
jour on en a recensé moins de 2 millions
sur l'ensemble de la terre
[Musique]
la plupart de ces êtres surnaturels
n'ont pas encore de nom court en ne
sachant rien deux ans les désigne par
des sobriquets voici par exemple le
poulpe à oreille
[Musique]
à l'abri des tourments de notre
atmosphère
la nonchalance a encore sa place la
chimère spatule cousine des requins est
un de ces fossiles vivants des abysses
qui n'ont pas évolué depuis l'époque des
premiers dinosaures
[Musique]
on imaginait que dans un milieu dépourvu
de plantes les créatures amorphe comme
ce poisson grenadiers survivaient
exclusivement grâce à la matière
organique qui tombe de la surface
c'est en partie vrai en sombrant au fond
elle nourrit des bactéries que dévore
quelques survivants de l'ombre mais le
fond des océans n'est pas uniforme
on y trouve des vallées des cagnottes
des montagnes et dans la ceinture de feu
du pacifique des montagnes très
particulière
leurs nombreuses fissures laisse filtrer
l'énergie du centre de la terre laquelle
énergie chaudes et aux riches en sels
minéraux
c'est ce court bouillon qui attire les
bactéries elle compose ici un grand
tapis blanc
l'eau est soumise à des pressions tel
quel bout au delà de 100 degrés une
fontaine de jouvence pour les bactéries
[Musique]
des cousines du bernard l'hermite légale
at t et berges et cultive des bactéries
dans lé soin qui tapissent leurs
appendices
c'est tellement plus commode pour les
manger
enfin dans cette tour de babel il y à
celles qui ont trouvé une niche étroite
au coeur des eaux tièdes les crevettes
d'alvin du nom du sous marin qui les a
récemment découvertes elles se font un
plaisir de nettoyer les résidents de ces
oasis blanche les galates et moules et
autres crustacés anonymes sont couverts
d'animal kull fort nourrissant
dans les abysses la couleur des
crevettes varie du blanc au rouge selon
que la matière organique qu'elle absorbe
provient de la surface où des bactéries
ont dit les crevettes d'alvin aveugle
mais en réalité leurs yeux se sont
adaptés aux conditions de vie des
abysses si elle ne voit pas la lumière
solaire
on pense qu'elles perçoivent à courte
distance les faible rayonnement
infrarouge comme ceux qui sont émis par
l'eau chaude
[Musique]
toutes proportions gardées c'est le
phénomène du fait rare dans quand on le
chauffe
il irradie une lumière orangée
les crevettes sont ainsi renseigner sur
leur environnement dans une eau trop
chaude par exemple elles n'ont aucune
chance de trouver des moules à ébarber
car celle-ci ne vivent que dans les eaux
à 10 ou 15 degrés
au sortir des cheminées hydrothermales
les eaux chaudes moins dense que l'eau
glacée ambiante s'élève rapidement
elles constituent de puissants
ascenseurs dont profitent parfois les
fantômes des abysses
c'est au pied de ces catapulte naturel
que les crevettes d'alvin festoient
c'est également ici qu'elle sème la
prochaine génération
quelques milliers de est close en
quittant l'abdomen de leur génitrice
[Musique]
on appelle au et ses larves de crevettes
quand les eaux chaudes crachées par les
cheminées se dissipe dans la masse de
l'océan
les jeunes crevettes sont emportés par
les courants marins livrés sans défense
à tous les appétits
la zoé est infiniment vulnérables
heureusement au contraire de ses parents
aveugle elle possède de grands yeux à
face est tout à fait fonctionnel et à
quoi peuvent-ils bien lui servir puisque
les sources hydrothermales la propulse
dans le noir infinie
[Musique]
a repéré par exemple les créatures
bioluminescente comme cette méduse cube
qu'il faut si possible éviter à cause de
ces longs tentacules de nîmes
[Musique]
contre danger en vue la méduse à tola et
son incroyable gyrophare
[Musique]
ce sont parmi les plus gros prédateur
dont la zoé doit se garder elle se
trouve déjà dans le zooplancton cette
soupe grouillante de l'arve et d'animaux
qui s'entre dévorent les plus abondants
des temps les larmes de copenhague
elles ne sont pas lumineuse toutefois
leur nage saccadé émet des vibrations
qui permet à la zoé de les localiser
dans l'obscurité la zoé elle est plus
discrète dans ses déplacements
elle possède sur ses pattes déçoit
plumeuses que son office de rames
rudimentaire
c'est suffisant pour esquiver des
prédateurs aussi indolent que l'abattage
boulotte les voici un ennemi autrement
plus dangereux le calmar de verre il
utilise sa transparence comme camouflage
cependant la zoé perçoit très bien de
ronds lumineux les yeux du calmar dont
la rétine opaque réfléchi la moindre
lueur une autre chose trahi le calmar
translucide la poche opaque en forme de
cigare qui lui tient lieu de rein et
d'estomac
curieusement cette glande et toujours
verticale
quelle que soit la position du calmar
[Musique]
malgré ces minuscules ram la zoé n'a pas
de réelle autonomie elle est soumise à
la même condition que la grouillante
communauté du plancton celle de
l'errance aléatoire
les courants l'entraînent parfois dans
d'invisibles rivière sous marine qui
épouse les reliefs des abysses
[Musique]
rivés sur le fond les gorgones elle
écrit no id lointain cousin des oursins
ap
au passage ce flux de protéines
[Musique]
tel est leur vie depuis plus de 400
millions d'années
lorsque ces rivières buts sur les flancs
d'un volcan sous marin
elle remonte vers la surface entraînant
avec elle le zooplancton
[Musique]
vous
la zoé parvient jusqu'à la zone fatick
c'est à dire les couches dans lesquels
pénètre les rayons du soleil
[Musique]
même si ses yeux sont adaptés à la
lumière ce monde n'est pas le sien
aussi dès qu'elle n'est plus porté par
les courants ascendants elle cherche à
redescendre dans les ténèbres le domaine
où s'opèrera sa métamorphose
[Musique]
pendant ce temps la sterne sillonnent
toujours l'océan en quête de ses
semblables
elle a mis le cap sur une autre île
déserte de l'arc de toit fois hung à
tonga la montagne des tonga
[Musique]
désertée par les hommes cette parenthèse
de verdure en plein océan n'en est que
plus attirante pour les sternes
une foule inespéré il doit peut-être
plusieurs milliers
[Musique]
appréciez longs mois passés en vol les
choses iront très vite pour la jeune
femelle mettre un peu d'ordre dans son
plumage trouver un partenaire pour toute
la vie se reproduire monde mâles et
femelles se relaient auprès de neuf
c'est la règle et déjà la voilà repartie
péché à charge pour le mâle de veiller
sur l'oisillon à venir juché sur une
noix de coco
la femelle guette le signe qui annoncera
un arrivage de poisson un premier repas
pour le petit ogre qui sur l'île en son
absence a déjà éclos
[Musique]
on
sur ce terrain de pêche sans limites les
monts sous marins sont les alliés des
sternes
le long de leurs pentes remonte la manne
des profondeurs
[Musique]
l'afflux de plancton attire des poissons
il en faut davantage pour que la sttr ne
repère la zone de pêche
pour l'instant rien ne paraît en surface
suivant son instinct elle épie la
moindre des formations de l'undd à
l'horizon
voici enfin un indice prometteur les
remous provoqués par quelques grands
prédateurs en maraude
les requins de haute mer comme ces
requins soyeux sont au sommet de la
chaîne alimentaire des courants
ascendants
ils encerclent les bancs de poissons
occupés à se gaver de plancton et les
poussent vers la surface
rassemblés en un groupe compact sous
cette barrière naturelle
les poissons sont plus faciles à dévorer
c'est cette agitation qu'à repérer la
sterne les poissons restent pour
l'instant inaccessible pour elle comme
pour toutes les sternes fuligineuses
qu'ils ne doivent pas plonger par chance
d'autres grands poissons vont projeter
les petits à travers le miroir des tons
[Musique]
que le festin commence
mais
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notre stern a le gosier chargés de
poisson il lui faut à présent leur
apporter aussi frais que possible à son
poussin et donc retrouver le plus court
chemin vers unga tonga pour se repérer
elle se fit aux astres et au soleil on
pense même que son cerveau est capable
de détecter le champ magnétique de la
terre
c'est un peu comme si elle naviguait à
la boussole et au sextant
juste au dessous d'elle mais à des
milliers de mètres de profondeur
la larve de la crevette d'alvin est
devenu adulte en voyageant à travers son
firmament sous marins ce qui la sauve
les humeurs changeantes de la terre à
sources hydrothermales où elle avait
éclos s'est tarie plus d'eau chaude et
de minéraux plus de bactéries la blanche
valait des crevettes d'alvin ressemble à
un cimetière
[Musique]
en pleine eau la crevette n'est guère
moins vulnérables adultes qu'à l'état de
larve
car en se métamorphosant ses yeux ce
sont atrophiés comme ceux de ses parents
et sont devenus insensibles à la lumière
ainsi elle ne voit pas approcher cet
avis est ruban un mètre vingt de long
750 vertèbres un record dans le monde
animal une anguille muni d'un bec
d'oiseau sur chacun de ses flancs une
ligne latérale un radar filiforme
détecte les vibrations émises par ses
proies
ce qui va soulever la crevette d'alvin
c'est sa façon toute particulière de se
déplacer en agitant souplement ces
petits tram au lieu de nager par
saccades comme ses cousines
elle devient furtive donc imperceptible
pour l'anguille
[Musique]
elle ne peut pas voir non plus les
dangereux filaments des méduses
[Musique]
en revanche dans ce champ de mines
plongé dans le noir éternelles elles
détectent grâce à ces antennes leurs
vibrations convulsive
où
[Rires]
[Musique]
ces antennes décèle aussi autre chose de
lointaines détonations son instinct
langage à nager vers l'origine de ces
sons ils semblent provenir des pentes
d'un bon marin où les courants
ascendants deviennent turbulent la voici
embarqués dans cet ascenseur
[Musique]
sur ces pentes d'étranges radar tente de
capter les dépêches des abysses ce sont
des tunis y est prédateur
totalement invisible aux yeux de la
crevette imperceptible à ses antennes
[Musique]
la crevette nomades a échappé à ces
bouges goulue et est bien la dernière
épreuve
il est rare que les crevettes et autant
de chances des millions de larves
disparaissent avant même d'avoir
accompli leur métamorphose emporté
maintenant vers le haut de la colline
la miraculée perçoit un effluve de
souffre de plus en plus prononcé et les
détonations semble se rapprocher
elle distingue enfin un léger
rayonnement infrarouge qui comme près
des sources hydrothermales trahi la
présence d'eau chaude
au sommet l'énigme se dénoue sur un
spectacle pyrotechnique inédit une
éruption volcanique abyssal
avec la pression phénoménale et le froid
qui règne ici
les blocs de lave projeté se solidifie
instantanément gaz dissous et grains de
cendres s'accumulent dans le panache
on estime que les trois quarts des
roches et des gaz crachés par la terre
proviennent de ces volcans sous marins
chaque année nombre d'entre eux
s'embrase dans la plus grande discrétion
leurs volutes se dissipe subrepticement
dans l'océan
[Musique]
du bruit donc des vibrations un panache
donc dû souffrent de la chaleur donc un
rayonnement infrarouge
de quoi stimuler tous les sens de la
crevette d'alvin un nouvel habitat la
crevette s'y installent
sur les flancs de ce volcan l'eau froide
sous pression pénètre dans les fissures
de la roche et se réchauffe au contact
du magma
elle ressort acide et minéralisées
singulièrement les crevettes d'alvin
prolifèrent ici alors qu'elle n'y trouve
pas la moindre moules les aurait chauffé
par le magma ressorte tellement acide
que les moules ne peuvent y construire
leur coquille
alors comment se nourrissent les
crevettes
on
[Musique]
en jouant les ramasse miettes des crabes
pullulent autour des sources
hydrothermales des hordes de cannibales
les crevettes d'alvin se tiennent prêts
des crabes lorsqu'ils mangent pour
happer à l'aveuglé miettes de chair qui
leur échappe
[Musique]
voilà pour la nourriture ordinaire mais
certaines crevettes les plus chanceuses
trouve d'autres mais pourquoi les plus
chanceuses parce que rares sont celles
qui survivent aux éboulements volcanique
soudain et violent
[Musique]
nombre de crevettes meurent brûlés à
l'acide écrasés par des scories ou
bouilli vivent leurs congénères rescapés
s'empresse de les dévorer
la grande gagnante de ce concours de
survie est une crevette d'alvin qui
s'offre un festin cannibale des
crevettes d'une autre espèce plus petit
après cela elle aura peut-être la force
de défier les courants qui accompagne
l'ascension du volcan
[Musique]
les volcans sous-marins sont soumis
comme les autres aux lois de la gravité
malgré ces éboulements il progresse sur
une base solide construisant peu à peu
un cône qui peut être atteindra un jour
la surface
[Musique]
il y à de grands bâtisseurs par lui ces
volcans ainsi le métis shaul qui a fait
surgir sa forteresse dans l'arc de thau
fois ces roches riches en silice très
compact résiste fort bien à l'érosion
marine
[Musique]
un nouveau relief sur la surface plane
de l'océan est un repère de plus pour
les navigatrices comme la sternes
fuligineuses sans prendre le temps de
faire halte sur cette nouvelle terre
elle poursuit sa route vers le havre de
rumba tonga où elle doit nourrir son
poussin et prendre le relais de son
partenaire
la montagne de tonga semblait en lieu
sûr
[Musique]
c'est oublié qu'elle était aussi
un volcan
un volcan qui s'est brièvement réveillé
pendant que la sterne pêcher ses
congénères ont disparu
[Musique]
lille s'est offert une extension sous la
forme d'une terrasse de cendres
agrémenté d'une piscine d'eau acide et
travaux d'aménagement n'ont duré que
quelques jours
il
la piscine chauffée circulaire comme un
cratère au dessus de l'eau bouillante
l'air se charge de vapeur sulfuré
délétère
roumegas tonga n'est plus un refuge mais
un lieu terriblement hostile
des pierres ponces témoigne de la
violence de l'explosion qui a surpris
les oiseaux
[Musique]
et anéantit la végétation
des répliques de tremblement de terre
secoue encore les falaises
[Musique]
presque toute l'île est couverte d'une
couche de cendre brûlante
beaucoup de jeunes stern et leurs
parents ont péri dans ce cataclysme
le poussin est le compagnon de la
femelle sont ils au nombre des victimes
plus une feuille aux arbres
[Musique]
on
partout des oeufs abandonnés
[Musique]
les mouches
seuls quelques oiseaux réfugier en
hauteur ont résisté
[Musique]
son poussin qui niche est à même le sol
est introuvable
quant à son partenaire peut être s'est
il échappé avant d'être asphyxié par les
fumées nocives
mais ce pépiements la sterne le
reconnaîtrai entre mille c'est la
signature sonore de son oisillons il
appelle mais où est il
[Musique]
j
shi
à l'abri de cette scories il a été
épargnée par la pluie de cendres et le
soleil cuisant
son père lui n'a pas survécu
pour nourrir son poussin la mère ne peut
désormais compter que sur elle-même et
sur l'océan
un spectacle inhabituel si près du
rivage les chandelles des baleines à
bosse ces femelles ont quitté
l'antarctique il ya quelques semaines
pour aller mettre bas dans les eaux
chaudes et tropic un très long voyage
pendant lequel elle jeunes à l'aller
comme au retour vivent sur leurs
réserves de graisse
elles doivent donc économiser leur
énergie par un heureux hasard
celles ci sont passés près de hung à
tonga juste après l'éruption les eaux
qui entoure l'île sont aussi chaude que
celle des tropiques aussi les baleines
décide-t-elle de mettre au monde leur
petit ici même
[Musique]
des nuages de soufre auréole roumegas
tonga depuis son éruption
ils sont alimentés par des bulles de gaz
qui transpire sur les flancs du volcan
c'est le même phénomène que celui des
sources hydrothermales des abysses seule
la profondeur change les eaux même les
autres surfaces sont réchauffées là
aussi par leur contact avec le magma
[Musique]
heureuse les baleines à bosse qui ont pu
raccourcir leur voyage elles auront
davantage de temps pour folâtrer avec
leurs nouveaux nés avant de se laisser
séduire par les cabrioles des mâles
pour un solide qu'il soit ce spectacle
ne détourne pas la sterne de son
objectif elle a son petit glouton à
nourrir mais il n'est plus question de
s'éloigner des jours durant pour aller
partager les festins des tons
heureusement juste au pied de l'île
calciné cette même éruption qui a tué
tant de stern a également stimulé la vie
sur ces pentes ancré dans les
profondeurs les autres sortes chaude est
chargé de minéraux après leur intrusion
dans la roche en fusion au coeur du
volcan
de nouveau des bactéries forment le
premier maillon d'une chaîne alimentaire
porté par des tourbillons à sand cette
fois à cause de la partie émergée du
cône les courants et tout ce qu'il
charrie remonte jusqu'à la surface
[Musique]
c'est aux bleus qui fondent les nappes
sulfuré viennent directement des abysses
[Musique]
dès le coucher du soleil une patrouille
colorait surgit des profondeurs rejoint
ce mouvement montant des calmars
[Musique]
plus qu'une patrouille une armée entière
venus prélever un maillon de la chaîne
les innombrables poisson
au clair de lune ils chassent là où les
courants s'arrête juste sous la surface
[Musique]
ces noctambules gardent leur mystérieuse
habitudes et revêtent leurs habits de
lumière
[Musique]
les scintillements n'échappe à l'oeil
des survivantes de roumegas tonga
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'aube tous les navigateurs regagnent
leur port d'attache
[Musique]
le poussin vous a déjà revenir sa mère
est là le gosier rempli mais de quoi
[Musique]
c'est un trésor des abysses qu'elle lui
apporte du calmar bijoux
chaque petits cris de la jeune stern est
un stimulus invitant sa mère à
régurgiter un poussin est capable
d'engloutir plus du tiers de son poids
en un seul repas et lui en faut un tout
les 16 heures faute de partenaire pour
la relayer
la mère devra constamment péché pour
l'approvisionner cette abondance de
nourriture facilement accessible
explique pourquoi tant de sternes
fuligineuses choisissent d'élever leurs
petits sur ces imprévisibles oasis
nice est sur une île volcanique est
risqué mais pouvoir pêcher tout près de
la côte et à la surface de l'eau est un
précieux avantage pour un oiseau qui ne
doit pas mouiller ses plumes
[Musique]
les crevettes d'alvin sont
irrésistiblement attiré par ce même
volcan comme les sternes
elles peuvent y trouver à la fois la
mort et la vie mais les crevettes saav
elles aussi tiré parti des habitats créé
par les éruptions sur les pentes sous
marine la nouvelle génération livre déjà
des milliers de zoé au courant ascendant
l'objectif de ces jeunes pionnière se
nourrir et grandir mettre à profit leur
sens exceptionnel pour trouver le chemin
des sources vital
mais rares sont celles qui redescendront
saine et sauve les plus petites se
feront dévoré par les plus grandes
d'autres seront aspirés par les courants
comme les volcans sous-marins auxquels
elles doivent la vie elles vont
rencontrer pour la première fois le
monde de la lumière
et ses dangers
non
[Musique]
lee